we do have good news on this front
though check out this story from fox
news group that works to elect gop
officials at state level showcases
record fundraising hall republicans look
to strengthen their upper hand in
control of state legislative chambers i
think at this point the state
is the most important
function right right now and people are
heavily focused on congress and the
senate and the presidency
but there's a huge opportunity right now
i think people are seeing it which group
is that tim did they name it so this is
how i got to scroll down a little way
this is our uh the republican state
leadership committee okay we'll announce
wednesday that along with its strategic
policy partner the state government
leadership foundation it hauled in a
combined 8.3 million dollars in
fundraising through july in during the
july september period which the rslc
said is the most it's ever brought in in
the third quarter of an odd year
so that's that's that that's massive
they say they noted that 19 million uh
that the 19 million dollars it and the
sglf have brought in through the first
nine months of the year exceeds the
total the two groups raised in all of
2019 which was the compare uh the
comparable off election year in the 2020
cycle
this is good this is big it's huge if
the states
all just start saying look california
illinois new york oregon whatever we
don't care maybe washington
we're all in favor of these changes the
states can do it without the federal
government's involvement we were talking
about this yesterday especially when it
comes to gun rights that have actually
been expanding comparatively on the
state level not on the federal level and
when you look at the states that passed
constitutional carry that list keeps
growing it's going to keep growing and
that's an amazing thing and as i said
yesterday i'm not hopeful at all at the
federal system the local system i do
have some optimism but we also have to
acknowledge here that the republicans
are kind of at war with each other you
have the the liz cheney mitt romney
lindsey graham party and then you have
the rand paul
um
thomas macy and other representatives of
the party that are absolutely totally
different
on a spectrum that's very wide so so
even if republicans do get in i'm still
to be honest skeptical of them i think
people should be skeptical of
politicians because there's a chance
that again the same corporations that
support the left support the right um
and it could just turn out to be
another situation where we're just going
back in circles but i think there are
more people now gravitating toward the
rand paul the massey section you know
look you made a good point about guns
i'm glad you brought it up it goes to
what i said about you show
you show them a little bit of fear and
they'll back off the reason obama never
went after guns he saber-rattled and he
claimed he was because he knew he could
never sell yeah southern trump would
across trump went after guns more than
obama ever did yeah and his base put up
with it and that
that infuriated me and his base put up
with it they put up with with the um
with the uh
stuff which was ridiculous one incident
one
here's what i'm trying to say though
even biden's people who are politically
savvy
understand that if they were to try to
pass sweeping gun reform mansion cinema
and tester could never go
unless they just wanted to be
crushed
in primaries by more conservative dems
and then crushed in the general by ours
they know they can't get this pest the
one issue that the dems will always
saber out a lot but they're terrified of
losing seats we need to do that with
every issue we need people in the state
legislatures and in congress who put
that fear into them on every issue and
we just refuse to elect them because we
keep electing that you know i think liz
cheney is going to lose her primary by
about 50.
because south dakota
wyoming rather is not happy with it look
christie gnome was one of the most
popular governors in the country a
couple of missed statements she's toast
i'd like to see uh 28th amendment and it
can be really simple it just says um re
second amendment
yeah not be infringed we're asserting it
actually it could be i'm joking but it
can be more a bit more specific all
legislation uh related to uh gun gun uh
gun ownership is hereby
revoked gone that's eliminated or amend
the second and just put that comma that
we always should have put the right of
the people to keep him bear arms because
we understand how tyrannical a
government can be and and add something
about it is an individual right
the right boom should not be infringed
it used to actually say that you know
regardless of military service you can
bear arms but they were worried it would
be argued you could avoid conscription
or something like that so they said
we'll simplify it but now we have you
know i we went to uh the gun store the
other day and i got a calico m100s it's
a fun little crazy thing the boba fett
gun and uh you can't have it maryland so
it's in my house in west virginia and
i'm just like you know we get all of
these democrats saying no one's trying
to take your guns away no just i'm like
dude it's a 22. yeah it's like it and
they call it an assault weapon yo they
are taking our guns away all the time
there's a huge list of guns you can't
have in all of these places so when they
say the right to keeping baron should
not be infringed and you literally can't
own an m1a which is not some futuristic
sci-fi power weapon
then you it's bs
so i'll i'll tell you what we can do a
lot of good with the convention of
states i'd be really happy if we just
had any one of these members of congress
to at least try
to repeal some of these garbage laws or
how about this there can be two laws
proposed by any one of these you know
populist candidates right now i'm not
seeing it repeal the nfa
and perhaps some some overarching
legislation protecting the rights of of
individuals with the power of the
federal government from states who seek
to oppress their rights to keep human
beings listen i think you get a populist
candidate who just proposes to repeal
the nfa and abolish the department of
education
and the irs
you guys are getting me uh excited here
like watch out like holy well i i wonder
if if someone ran on abolish the irs
would that would that win what i mean
because you got to think about that i
think they would audit their campaign to
the point they crippled them but think
about this what i mean what the
republicans would be like what do we do
like if we go after this person we'll
lose support so they'd be too timid and
scared like the established republicans
the democrats would be running campaign
saying the irs is good
yeah they would and how many people who
have like ira there's those commercials
where it's like in trouble with the irs
yeah call us today and we'll negotiate
those people are going to be like i'll
vote for him that's right i mean jet
they're already doing it janet yellen
came out and said the irs rule requiring
banks to report report all transactions
over 600
is something that is worthwhile to do
she's defending that policy and saying
we need to implement it if we had a
convention of states i'd love to see
some wacky stuff and i don't mean like
overtly wacky just like as soon as it's
called some guy goes
uh amendment 28 abolish the irs here
here and they'll bang the gavel uh
amendment 29 atf next you got it bang
bang bang but that's what would put the
fire got into that that's exactly what
i'm talking about fbi see you later boom
you know i mean that's what we need to
do because we we've let's face it
there's no reason whatsoever that we
should have i think today as we sit here
there are 144 federal law enforcement
agencies
bureau land management has a law
enforcement agency department of
education has one department of the
interior has one
it's ludicrous it is absolutely
ludicrous federal protective service
runs around and they guard federal
buildings that have other law
enforcement agencies in them that have
their own uniform divisions that could
guard the building
the amount of waste the amount of
taxpayer money wasted on this and
look the creation
it was the creation of of a of an
authoritarian police state but it was
also the normalization of it right
people are so used to seeing
so many different federal agencies that
carry guns and badges and can lock you
up and talk about the us code right
every american wakes up in the morning
and does something to violate some
criminal statute in either the u.s code
their state law or county ordinance
everybody even including like toddlers
who get up in the morning it's it's
ludicrous and i think we need real
reform in terms of repellation of bills
but you'll never see a bill repealed i
had a conversation about six years ago
with a very conservative put that in
quotes florida state senator
and i asked him this i said look we're a
red state we pride ourselves on me and
conservatives i think rick scott was
governor at the time
why don't we repeal anything and he said
and i almost choked on my drink he said
we're legislators we legislate i said
but you're supposed to be a conservative
he says yeah but our legislation is
conservative i wanted to bang my head on
the table
they should have sunset clauses written
into them every bill every bill every
bill recently the government ran out of
money they're like we don't have enough
money we got to raise the debt ceiling
how about you stop spending money you
don't have i mean why is that such a
crazy idea
now mcconnell we don't have
conservatives even arguing against that
and uh
hold on the institute for policy studies
literally came out that at the average
day an american commits three felonies
yeah so the us government is an abusive
significant other who is a deadbeat
doesn't work threatens you you come home
smacks you around and says give me the
money you know i love you yeah they only
do it because they love you yeah yeah
the federal government loves you right
now it's really bad and and uh the
problem is we're now normalizing it even
more right so with crt and with wool
culture kids are being conditioned to
believe that the fbi persecuting people
who listen tell you guys a story which
is chilling i've got a friend who's on
one of the jtts the joint terrorism task
forces which if your viewers listeners
don't know those are fbi managed task
forces in pretty much every major city
every major region that includes state
police local cops other agents from
federal agencies this is one in the
northeast in a large area
his team alone there are dozens of these
around the country his team alone
received in one month almost 200
referrals from doj from fbi's washington
field office
on january 6th suspects 77 warrants on
the bank accounts of people who weren't
even in dc
on january 6th
they didn't receive one referral on
antifa or blm not one and when they
asked why they were told stand down
leave it alone now that's one jttf team
all right if you don't think the fbi has
been weaponized for political
persecution you're not paying attention
and this is from a guy who built his
media career first on supporting
analyzing and defending law enforcement
it's abysmal it's chilling what's
happening here they have weaponized that
agency but that's the entire government
every instance that agency has been
politicized from its very beginning with
j edgar hoover and what he was doing
against jfk mlk it was absolutely
disturbing to see the start of this
federal agency that has been continuing
to be extremely political when they're
not supposed to be and they don't really
have a mission anymore the fbi they're
like a sea of generalists
in a field of specialists right dea does
drugs atf does guns they shouldn't but
they do uh hsi is doing terror and and a
lot of the child porn and child
trafficking you know if fbi wants to be
investigators for doj do public
corruption fine
their national security branch we
thought was effective until we saw what
they did in the trump russia case i
think heads need to roll for that still
but it's an agency really without a
specific mission
and every uh when you're a hammer
everything looks like an ailment this is
why i've been saying abolish the police
for the past several months
right now we're at this period where i
mean you look to australia
nightmarish oh you can't travel i mean
these videos that are coming out are
getting increasingly crazier people have
to take pictures of their faces
otherwise the cops show up in the united
states you have conservative areas they
want they want a right to keep and bear
arms some of these conservative areas
are in blue states where they have no
right and it is the police who will come
and arrest you for accessing your second
amendment right there's a story i often
tell of a woman who was lives in
pennsylvania and had a legal concealed
carry and crossed the bridge to jersey
not you know didn't think didn't
understand yeah i spoke to that woman i
i know who you're talking about because
there's a famous story right yeah yeah
they turned her like she ended up trying
to charge her on my show it was terrible
she had a permit in pennsylvania right
and she came into jersey made her
actually just made a wrong turn off the
highway wound up in jersey was pulled
over and they wanted to put her in like
that and that wasn't that was a police
officer who did that police officer then
then federal charges applied because she
came across state lines it was so so
what i say is this look if you're in a
conservative area and you're very much
pro responsibility personal
responsibility gun rights then you're
not really worried about the police for
the most part shanine allen that was her
name
so so we we're in the middle of nowhere
there's there's not cops nearby you know
we we don't have a large we have a
sheriff's department we can call and
maybe they'll show up eventually we it's
mostly for administrative stuff if
something happens the responsibility the
onus is on us to defend ourselves and
protect our protect our rights and the
best we can and then afterwards as soon
as you know whatever conflict is being
resolved you you try and get the police
to come and sort things out in big
cities
you don't live in a big city
conservatives don't live there why are
they supporting big city cops who the
left are complaining about if the left
says they don't want police then then
okay then we're in agreement we don't
live there we don't care about how you
want to live let them live the way they
want thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time